yeah I I have a genuine question you
know um you believe God was in in
woman's private part right just honest
question just honest question why I'll
answer this if you answer mine do you do
you believe that God blew into a women's
private part I believe God uh I I
believe God
said because God is Almighty that's not
what I asked you I asked you do you
believe that God blew into a woman's
priv
I believe I believe Allah
said so when your Quran says that Allah
blew Mary's far what is that but your
God was in a woman's private trying to
shift the question I had a question
first I told you I can answer it if you
answer mine but your you're insecure if
you answer mine but why can't you answer
in private part it says that Allah blew
into Mary's mariam's Farge what is that
what did he what did he put his lips on
Allah only Allah all right I got you and
then and how I answer to you Allah only
God knows no you're you're claiming
Jesus Is God right no no no be honest be
honest Allah hold on let me my on let me
give you my Allah song just one second
one second one second one second I got
are you trying are you trying to mock I
don't I don't understand why you're
giving a show we're we're trying to
speak about God oh you don't respect God
you're trying to get song I don't
respect okay okay you don't respect you
don't respect
God you're playing music while God how
can you say it's respectful oh my
God
childish child
[Music]
I that's my song man Allah Allah just
gave me the faith baby I ain't got to
answer your question okay let's try no
no let's try let's try to speak
seriously because you're trying to to
Mock and to play with religion while I'm
as a Muslim I'm taking it serious I'm
only giving you what you're giving me my
brother okay okay let me ask you same
energy you no problem okay how do you
believe how do you believe Jesus was
born tell me please the same the same
standards that you give me and you place
on me the same criteria I question for
you as well yeah okay but but my
question is how do you believe God was
born oh no Jesus I'm sorry because it's
Jesus right do you have do you have an
argument my brother let's let's try to
progress this yeah yeah I'm I'm trying
to to ar ar
I'm sorry yeah do you have an argument
against the deity of Christ yeah I'm I'm
saying it to you I'm I'm asking you
because God is Almighty go God is all
powerful so you're now claiming and and
and and um you can correct me if I'm
wrong please correct me but you're
claiming God your God was a baby at the
moment he he needed someone to to to
carry him he needed someone to care for
him that's my question just be clear so
your argument is
the Incarnation where God decides to be
born of a woman takes on human flesh and
is born of a woman and you're saying
that that he not God I'm asking you do
you believe it is it is just like that
that that God placed himself in that
situation do you believe that as a
Christian yeah I believe that God took
on flesh and was born of a woman born of
a virgin are you saying that that goes
against like that is an argument against
the deity of Christ and if so tell me
how I can I can uh give you multi
sources from your uh book I can claim uh
multiple um verses that okay I have one
question before I I'm going to your
question you already asked a question
about no I I have just one question
where did Jesus claim okay no problem no
problem so please tell me why did uh
when did Jesus say in the Bible exactly
worship me tell me you have my fiance
Laughing Man can you be quiet maybe it's
a gin no yeah maybe it is a gin maybe
it's your Christianity I don't know
theism theism is strong in this one bud
it's a fine fine this yeah theism is
strong
bro does she cover like Mary does she
cover does she cover herself oh okay
okay I'm sorry yeah of course I I know
that uh like like to to get out of these
conversations you have to um like you
you want me to kick you and and you know
you I don't got it's a it's a it's a I'm
I'm chill here man CH here so you're
just showing You're just showing how
weak Islam is you know
no I'm relax you mocking God how can
I so you asked me where does Jesus say
exactly in the exact words worship me
right okay my here's my question if he
doesn't say the exact words worship me
does that mean he never demanded worship
no but if we go
if you're going to lay down foundations
is your is your book trust Worth or not
can I just can I just so if if those
exact words don't determine whether or
not he demanded worship or not then your
question should be this servant of Allah
did Jesus demand worship and if so how
that should be your question yeah but
how can I know how how can I know
exactly that the book that came huh the
New Testament that you have 400 years
after Jesus the no no because how can
you claim that Jes you got to focus man
I know you're on you're up here you're
on the big stage so I know nerves are
shaking I can see only dirty racist in
this comment I can only see racism
focused be focused be focused so hold on
I got to fix this little puzzle thing
that Tik Tok is doing no wor all right
so when yeah it's racism guys disrespect
misogyny it's all good it's all good of
law yeah if so just as you recognize
Jesus does not have to say the exact
words worship me in order to demand
worship right yeah but before that we're
going to lay down foundations right
claim that Jesus words the foundation is
what you asked me to do your objection
was yeah show me where Jesus said
exactly worship me of course and so now
we're dealing with that so don't go
anywhere else Focus oh you don't want to
focus on the foundations right Focus
this is a foundation oh okay I see you I
see you I know I know I know so let me
ask you this yeah how do you honor Allah
by by worshiping him beautiful do you
give this type of Honor that you give to
Allah to a prophet or an angel or your
parents or anyone else worshiping no I
worship only Allah so worship is the due
honor that is only specifically for
Allah for God Alone got you that's how
you honor him beautiful with you all the
way this is what Jesus says Jesus said
that all are to honor the son the exact
same way they honor the father so that
honor that you give to the father to God
which is worship Jesus says you're
supposed to give that same honor to him
which is worship so Jesus demands
worship of you yeah that's John chapter
5 verse 23 yeah of course but if we yeah
you you answer it you answer it
correctly but how can you prove that's
Jesus word because if John said it you
automatically automatically think oh
it's Jesus words but how can you say how
can you say and you can claim that while
you you don't have the the the
manuscripts of the time of Jesus peace
be upon him you have the manuscripts the
codec anticus is the earliest one that
you have uh not even a big manuscript
and you're claiming by that by that
standard you're Jes clear just to be
clear you you are acknowledging that
Jesus demands Worship in the Bible right
I don't follow the Bible I'm sorry I
know you don't follow the Bible but you
are acknowledging that in the Bible
Jesus demands worship right yeah maybe
Paul said it or John said it but I just
I quoted you the verse my question was
clear you acknowled you acknowledge that
in the in the Bible Jesus demands
worship right no I don't believe it was
Jesus words by the beginning prove to me
that you asked me you asked okay so this
this is where I get confused you asked
me to show you in the Bible where Jesus
says exactly worship me so I just showed
you where Jesus said to worship him you
said that I answered correctly but now
you're saying like if for some reason
you're saying that's not it I'm confused
yeah the reason why is I I lay down the
question so that you will answer the
question but now I I came with a
follow-up question and that followup
question is pro to me is Jesus words my
friend we'll get to the followup of
course first can you acknowledge that I
answered your that this first one that I
showed you in the bible where jesus
demands worship I don't believe it's
Jesus that's my point okay so who's
speaking there in John 5:23 I don't
believe it's Jesus who's speaking there
if you can prove to me it's Jesus you
can you can according to according to
the verse again only God knows and don't
come with this song pleasee I'm I'm I'm
tired of it please ask your wife is is
it your wife or your girlfriend because
I don't know you marry the woman in
Christianity do you marry the woman no
okay ask her to cover like Mary please
[Music]
this can I say something can I can I can
I say say something Avery please you are
as you deal with me honestly in these
discussions ofone of I say I say one
thing hold on hold on bro hold on bro
course the second that you begin to be
dishonest in our discourse then your
dishonesty deserves to be mocked by the
way no problem start but you didn't mock
me you mocked God you didn't mock me
that's crazy part set the tone for this
you set the tone for this so because if
you came off disrespectful why when did
I came came off you came off playing
these games and now you're also being
dishonest all of this deserves to be
mocked your foolishness my first
question excuse me was it
disrespectful in front of 700 people is
being mocked because that's the energy
that you brought but please answer me is
your for take care of yourself you will
be mocked I'm going just let you guys
know here when you come on the platform
and you come on the platform
disrespectful you come on the platform
arrogant you come on the platform
dishonest you will be mocked